Right?
Well,
last time I was looking at the vitals,
social distinctions that were recognized
in the 16th century and also how people
conceived of society as a whole.
Um,
so today I want to come down to the other
end of the scale and look at the most
fundamental unit of society,
the household,
the unit in which most people spent their
lives and which govern most of their
daily activities.
So let's begin with some definitions.
Um,
the household can be defined in the first
instance as being a unit of residents.
Of course.
Uh,
but also as I indicated last time,
it was a unit of authority.
It's a group of people,
some related,
some unrelated living under the same roof,
under the authority of a household pen,
usually a man,
sometimes a widowed woman.
And in addition,
the household has been described
as a unit that was geared for work,
the work which was necessary to satisfy
its needs as a unit of production and of
consumption and of reproduction.
So all households had that much in common,
but they're very greatly in their size.
The composition and the complexity of
the relationships contained within them.
Uh,
if we go to the top of the social scale,
the households of the nobility and the
gentry could be very large institutions.
Indeed,
sometimes vast institutions,
uh,
they will organize to maintain not only
a noble family at an expected level of
magnificence,
and to be magnificent was one of the
qualities of a nobleman in contemporary
thought.
But also they were the centers
for administering landed estates.
They were the centers for
conducting local government.
They were,
the centers often have the
exercise of political power.
Uh,
to give just one example at Pontefract
castle in the more or less in the center
of the country in South Yorkshire Appear,
uh,
Pontefract castle was the home
of Lord Darcy and a list of his,
uh,
household as it was in 1521 survives.
There were 80 people in Darcy's household,
80,
his family members of his extended
family who lived with him,
his household,
and the state officers
he had living with him,
a bunch of young men who
were the sons of his clients,
amongst the local gentry and
numerous menial servants.
When he was called by Henry the eighth
to go to war against the Scots in 1523,
he took with him 23 young men who were
members of his household that is personal
guard wearing his livery.
So such people as Lord Dottie
had a style of life domain,
Tane,
which necessarily elaborated
their domestic established for us.
And these were the great
households of the age,
those of lesser people who are of course,
much smaller and much
less elaborate usually.
Basically they were
nuclear family households,
husband,
wife and children.
Rarely co-resident
relatives living with them.
And that's a matter of some significance.
Uh,
it reflects the common cultural assumption
that every newly married couples
should set up its own
independent household and
indeed that you should not marry
until he could do so.
You should not kill habit
with your relatives.
Well,
in many ways that sounds very modern,
but we mustn't forget that a large
minority of households in this period,
although their central
core was a nuclear family,
we're also much larger than average,
not because they had
kinsfolk living with them,
but because they came to include people
who were linked to the household,
not by blood or birth,
but by contract servants,
apprentices.
So if 16th century
households look familiar,
in some ways a large minority of
them were also very different,
and one could say,
um,
they different from modern households
in three essential respects.
They different structurally in that a
substantial number of them contained
people affiliated to the household by
contract the servants and apprentices.
They differed conceptually in that when
people talk about their family in this
period,
they meant not their immediate blood
relatives as we use the term they meant,
or members of their household.
Servants and apprentices were
regarded as members of their family.
They referred to them as family.
So there are different conceptually,
and they're also different functionally
because these people were usually taken
on for reasons which go beyond the
usual functions of a modern household.
Um,
whereas we tend to think of a household
as a unit of residents and consumption
and child rearing and
provision of emotional support.
All of that is true in
the 16th century too,
but the household in the 16th century
also had more extensive functions,
which we don't associate
with the household today.
There were units of production,
they will farms,
they will work shops.
They were also places of education and
training where the young were trained in
particular tasks and that's what
I mean when I say they were,
they were geared for work for all
these larger range of functions,
right?
Well,
as working units and
as units of residents,
all households were also
spheres of interdependence,
their maintenance and their depended
on the contributions of all of their
members.
As we saw last time.
This was in its ideology,
a patriarchal society.
Of course,
in the sense that authority
was conventionally located
in the persons of adult
males in general and adult male
householders in particular,
and these assumptions about
the structure of authority.
We're auto embodied in law.
Remember the law of property I mentioned
last time with regard to women,
but despite these constraints
of ideology and law,
women's role in the household
was of course indispensable.
And this was fully recognized.
It was the duty of the householder to
maintain his family by his Labor to
exercise his authority
in managing its affairs,
to play a part in training servants
and apprentices and so forth.
The duty of the mistress of the
household was generally summed up in a
contemporary word,
hustler,
furry.
It's on your,
it's on your sheet,
who?
Swiffer or housewifery
and that it comprised the range of
activity very different from the modern
notion of the housewife or the homemaker.
It wasn't so focused on the maintenance
of the domestic environment.
How has it in this period,
it's very simple.
Most people seem to have lived in rooms
and houses with two or three rooms
and furnishing was exceedingly sparse.
When people died,
inventories of their goods were drawn up.
And from them,
we can learn every single
possession that they,
they had.
Um,
and it's striking how sparse domestic
interiors were in this period.
To give you one example,
a craftsman from Lincolnshire,
which is up here,
uh,
who died in 1540.
His inventory survives and he possessed
only 22 items in all 22 items.
And they were items connected with
the three basics of household life,
places to sleep,
places to sit and things
to eat with horn spoons,
wooden bowls,
22 items in all,
not untypical.
So housewifery as they understood it in
the 16th century was concerned not so
much with managing the domestic
environment as with managing the daily
consumption needs of the household.
Food preparation of course central,
but also making and mending clothes and
bedding and general provision for the
maintenance of the household.
In 15,
23,
a man called Antonio Fitzherbert,
uh,
wrote a book called the Book of husbandry
and unity describes a domestic tasks
of a rural woman.
Uh,
and what he describes as a myriad of
activities involving the self provisioning
of household at this time,
keeping the pigs and the
poultry running the dairy,
growing hemp and flax,
spinning it into yarn for
making the linen for the family,
uh,
preparing the wool clip,
laboring in the fields and
in the barn when needed.
And marketing women seem to have taken
care of most of the regular marketing of
the produce of the house,
sold the eggs,
the poetry,
the pigs,
the grain,
uh,
and of course buying necessities
which couldn't be produced at home
in the households of urban
craftsmen and tradesmen.
Things were a little
differently organized.
Women were formerly excluded
from the apprenticeship,
which would enable them to
learn one of these trades,
but very often they learned
many aspects of it informally.
And the records reveal many glimpses of
women active in various aspects of their
husbands trades,
assisting their husbands as bakers and
butchers carrying water and sand for
husbands who are in the building trade,
buying raw materials on
their husband's behalf,
um,
selling the finished goods and so forth.
How do we know about things like this?
Well,
lots of records that survive from the
many courts which govern many aspects of
local life.
Um,
give us a little glimpses
of what people are doing.
We know that that women in,
in,
in one city,
uh,
well in Norridge actually,
um,
might be down at the water side by in
wood for husbands who were carpenters
because on one occasion a fight broke out
and what they were doing happens to be
described in the records.
You get these kinds of glimpses
of people's activities.
The wives of laboring men were less able
to participate in the household based
production of a craftsman's family because
their households were not productive
units.
They went out to work for others.
But you also find these women engaged
in all kinds of wage labor to make their
contribution to the domestic budget.
They might do seasonal agricultural labor
that you might find them spinning for
wages,
producing the yarn for the cloth industry.
They took in sewing and knitting and
washing and all kinds of other activities
outside the home in the city of
Chester up here in the northwest,
for example,
at the docks,
they had a crane which was
operated by a treadmill.
Someone had to stand inside of wheel
and tread it to make it turn to make the
crane operator,
uh,
who was inside the wheel women.
Um,
you also find many women engaged
in various forms of petty dealing.
Um,
one glimpse survives of a
woman called Rose Rose Hearst.
She lived in Mulder on the coast of
the county of Essex and we learned that
twice a week on market day,
she went 15 miles to the
county town to sell oysters.
I hope she had a pony.
So carrying a basket of ice
does 15 miles would be no joke,
but rose her soul dosages twice a week.
So overall women's tasks extended well
beyond the domestic sphere to include a
host of forms of self provisioning or
supplementary earning according to the
circumstances of different
kinds of household.
The mix would vary,
but the common characteristic of
that gender role was flexibility and
adaptability.
In what was expected of them.
Mary Pryor,
who's written an excellent article
on women's work in this period,
um,
sums it up.
She says,
what men did was definite,
well defined and limited
to their craft or trade.
What women did was everything else
in a way that's slightly unfair to men.
They worked very hard too,
but it's essentially true.
Well,
this constant round of
duties of house were free,
were conducted in the
context of a further role.
Women's reproductive role,
which is worth dwelling on a little.
Most couples in this period got
married in their mid to late twenties.
They married relatively late when they
were ready to set up their own household.
Yeah,
historical demographers who
researched the parish registers,
which give us the details of people's
marriages and the baptisms of their
children and so forth.
They've revealed that the average woman
could expect to have her first child
within 18 months of marriage
and she could then expect on average to
have another child at intervals of two
to three years for the
rest of her fertile life.
If you live that long,
think about it.
That means that the average woman in
16th century England was pregnant for a
quarter to a third of her entire adult
life and that they were constantly
besieged by the needs of small children.
These births being spaced across an
entire adult life meant that you know when
some children were teenagers and
ready to go out into service,
others,
this still toddlers and so forth,
constant demands of small children.
So it's not surprising that as Thomas
Tasha said in the mid 16th century
housewives affairs have never known end
housewives affairs have never non end
and despite their legal subordination,
it was of course on the performance of
these complex roles in adapt adapted to
circumstances that women's standing
as individuals depended amongst their
neighbors,
within their families and
from the performance of these
roles darkness that they
derive their self esteem
well in an agriculturally
dominated labor intensive,
low productivity,
pre mechanized and pre contraceptive age.
It could hardly be otherwise
and for the same reasons children
are expected to play their part to
only a small minority of children
would have formal schooling.
In the 16th century.
It's been estimated perhaps
10% in the early 16th century.
Most children would learn their life
skills practically at home or a servants.
And they were expected to begin that and
to participate in the domestic economy
as soon as they were able to do so.
That may sound exploitative,
but one mustn't exaggerate.
Such participation was an essential
part of their education for life and
children tended to be introduced
the tasks at an appropriate stage.
There's also plenty of
evidence of them playing,
but from the age of about seven or eight,
you find them regularly engaged in
tasks that they were able to manage.
Herding sheep and cows,
reaping,
gathering fuel,
fetching and carrying,
picking fruit,
scaring birds in the fields and,
and so on and so forth.
Um,
there's a remarkable study by Barbara
Hanawalt of Ohio State University of,
um,
children children's working
activities in this period,
which is based on the records of coroners.
Uh,
when someone died an untimely death,
um,
it had to be investigated by
the coroner just as today.
They already had that system.
Um,
and the records of coroners,
which survive,
which deal with the deaths of children
reveal what they were doing at the time
that they suffered an accident
leading to their death.
And so you can look at this and you have
their age and you can see what tasks
they were engaged in.
So for example,
you know,
a little boy is helping his father to
cut down a tree when the ax heads strikes
him and sadly he's killed or a little
girl is fetching water when she falls down
a well and so on and so forth
from evidence like this.
And imaginative historian can reconstruct
the way in which children will
gradually introduced
into their working life.
Sustained repetitive labor of the kind
we associate with exploitative child
labor was relatively
rare though it existed,
especially in the areas which were
heavily involved in the cloth trade.
That's where you find
children carding wools,
spinning wool for long hours.
So the household in the 16th century,
it was a unit geared for work and
its members roles varied according to
contemporary ideas and values
regarding the proper roles of men,
women,
and children.
So let's turn now to the priorities of
households and the strategies by which
they achieved them.
Well,
the first priority,
obviously enough was survival.
That meant maintaining the flow of
resources on which the household dependent
today that would be your
salary in the 16th century.
It meant various combinations of self
provisioning on the one hand and engaging
in markets on the other.
Most rural households were still heavily
weighted towards providing their own
basic subsistence.
It was still essentially a subsistence
economy of small producers relying
primarily on family labor and consuming
most of their produce in their own
houses.
Um,
of course that would vary
regionally and socially.
Um,
in most areas there was a minority of
those large yeoman farmers I mentioned
last time.
They were attuned to supplying um,
medium to long distance markets
with agricultural produce,
provisioning the towns and so forth.
And they were producers
on a substantial scale,
heavily engaged in marketing.
But it's been estimated by
the agricultural historian
Mark Overton that about
80% of English farming and the early 16th
century was actually oriented towards
the subsistence of the farm family itself.
And only a small part of
their produce being marketed.
Well,
whether the flow of household
resources depended on,
on self provisioning or
on selling in the market,
it provided people with their living
and often quite a bare living.
Um,
Overton whom I mentioned has
also calculated the incomes.
It could be,
it could be expected by farmers.
In this period a big yeoman who had a
hundred acres of land growing wheat could
not only feed his family,
but would probably earn Overton,
reckons about 70 pounds a year.
Quite a substantial income
from his production.
Um,
on the other hand,
a small husband,
men with only about 10 acres would
probably have only enough left to sell to
yield him two or three pounds a year.
So is an enormous difference in the
cash income that they could generate.
So for many of these families,
the smaller Husbandman,
they had a fairly narrow margin
and that was in normal times.
Um,
these estimates have to be transformed
when you get the event of a bad harvest.
Uh,
if the harvest failed,
a big farmer,
big yeoman farmer would still be
able to feed his family and prices,
which shoot up because of shortages.
So he might still make
a considerable income,
but in such circumstances,
the small farmer might not be
able to feed his own family.
He might fall behind on his rent,
he might have to buy grain in
the market at inflated prices.
It could be a disastrous circumstance.
And for landless wage earners,
it could be even harder.
They didn't produce their own food.
They would have to buy
it at very high prices.
Well,
bad years like that were relatively rare,
but they were unpredictable.
Um,
in the 1520s,
there were two very bad years like that.
Uh,
in the 1550s,
there were three,
there was another run,
a very bad harvest in the 50
nineties and so on could go on.
And it was one of the hazards of life.
One can understand why people sometimes
in the diaries that they left behind
them or looking anxiously at the
weather as the harvest approaches,
other sources of insecurity
could be equally unpredictable.
The high mortality rates of the
period could pose a real threat.
Uh,
the worst circumstances would
be the outbreak of an epidemic,
usually an epidemic of bubonic plague.
Uh,
when an epidemic hit a city,
as they periodically did,
you might get 20 or 30% of the entire
population dying within a period of
months.
Um,
the city of York,
the greatest city of the
north of England up here,
um,
York suffered no fewer than seven
epidemics of bubonic plague.
I'm between 40 and 85 and 15,
15.
So this was another hazard of life which
would periodically strike devastating
the households that were infected.
Besides epidemics,
though there was also the constant
threat of infectious diseases,
which nowadays would be
cleared up in a matter of days,
uh,
with antibiotics.
Um,
this meant that death
rates were fairly high,
um,
for adults.
Um,
very few people live till 60.
and also you have the hazards
of death in child bed,
uh,
for women.
Uh,
and of course accidental deaths.
These threats could hit the
prosperous and the poor alike.
And the accident of death at a bad
moment in any household could prove
absolutely disastrous.
This was a period that
had no life insurance.
It was a period which had no pensions
for those who were left behind.
Average life expectation at birth in
the 16th century was actually about 33
that's average.
If you made it to 20,
you will probably live to their forties,
but most people died in
their forties or fifties.
Okay.
All of these somber realities add up to
an environment of risk for the household
threatening its viability and survival,
and that inevitably influenced
people's mentalities.
It's been suggested that people in this
period tended to value security and
stability over change and growth.
There.
Economic Strategies in particular
were often very defensive,
uh,
designed to minimize risks rather
than to maximize opportunities.
So their first priority was survival.
The second major priority was to
provide for the future well being of the
members of the household and their
future capacity if they were young,
to be able to form and sustain how cells
have their own when they reached the
appropriate age.
And in this process,
there are three crucial moments in the
life of the household as the putting
forth of children into
the world as they put it.
There's marriage and the
arrangements associated with it,
and there was the transmission of
property to the new generation through
inheritance.
These are all aspects of the way in which
household would gradually dispersed.
Let's look first at the
aspect of dispersal involving
young people that they're
leaving home to enter the
households of others as servants.
And as apprentices,
the institution of service was well
attuned to accommodating the needs of
different households at
any one point in time.
Uh,
some households,
often the poorer ones would have children
who were coming to an age at which
they were capable of
a fuller working role,
but there wasn't really enough
to usefully employ them at home.
Their Labor wasn't needed.
Other households,
however,
would require additional labor,
uh,
either temporarily because
the children were young,
too young to work or permanently because
their children had grown and left home.
Um,
if you look at the back of your handout,
you'll see a couple of,
um,
examples of 16th century households.
That's 16th century
handwriting at the bottom.
This is from a census which was made.
Um,
these are the households of yeomen
farmers and you'll see that there are no
children in those households,
but there are lots of servants.
Some of them are described as husbandman
except that they're at their farm
workers living in the household
of these yeoman farmers.
And most of them,
as you'll see,
are pretty young.
They're in their late
teens or early twenties.
That's what 16th century households of
this particular type would have looked
like.
Well,
the basic logic of the system then
was the transfer of children from one
household to another,
according to need.
Um,
but there was also more to it than that.
Service was also a way in which
young people learn skills.
It was a way which they gain experience.
And of course they earned a small wage,
which they can often save.
It also served to kind of redistribute
the young across an area from the village
in which they were born.
Um,
they would move from master to master
around the area in which they lived.
Um,
and they would become familiar with the
economic opportunities available to them
in their region.
Um,
gradually when they reached
sufficient age and maturity,
um,
getting a notion of where
they're much settled permanently,
Mary and set up their own household.
Um,
they would often be hired annually at
a servant's hiring fan has been a very
good study of a hiring fair done by a
woman called Ann Kussmaul who's written an
excellent book on servants
and she shows how,
you know,
you would have a little town where the
hiring fair was and servants who might be
placed in households scattered around
the area would come in to get hired and
then they might be hired by a master,
which would take them out to the other
side of the particular catchment area of
this hiring fair.
So as you're gave way to,
your servants would be whizzing backwards
and forwards around this area and she
shows from year to year how that happened.
And then eventually they settled.
Okay.
Well,
a lot of this was relevant
to apprentices also.
But with the apprenticeship system of
course the advantages mechanism and the
skill training,
um,
aspect was much more prominent.
Families invested in the children
who went out as apprentices.
They paid a fee to their masters and they
expected that in future when they had
finished their apprenticeship,
they would set up his
master craftsmen themselves.
So service and apprenticeship where the
conventional ways of preparing young
people for the future assumption
of adult responsibilities.
And for most of them
that came with marriage,
marriage was the point at which they
were transformed into householders.
And like leaving home,
it was a point of transition at which
individual desires and individual
ambitions had to be reconciled with the
larger strategies of the households they
built,
they belong to
the making of a marriage
was quite a complex process.
It's left a lot of records and quite,
uh,
quite a few excellent.
Studies have been done a bit.
It was really simply a matter of parents
arranging the marriages of the young
that was certainly known.
Uh,
parents were more than happy to present
potential candidates to their children.
And amongst the aristocracy
arrangement of matches,
uh,
amongst their children,
um,
was very common.
Um,
these were families in which marriage
have great social and political
significance and it was too important
to leave to the young people themselves.
But in general,
young people were permitted a
considerable degree of personal choice in
selecting their marriage
partners provided they did.
So by choosing within a pool of
people who were considered acceptable,
that's to say a pool of eligible partners
of appropriate social and economic
standing.
They had an ideal of parity
in marriage like married.
Like when they talk of a match,
they mean exactly that they're matching
social equals and whether the courts
ships were initiated by the young
people themselves or whether they were
responding to initiatives and suggestions
taken by their parents or their
guardians.
This,
the successful completion of a match
was subject to what one historian has
called multilateral consent.
It's not a unilateral matter
for the young people alone.
It's not unilateral arrangement
by the parents alone.
It's a matter of multilateral consent.
That is to say the agreement and
support of all interested parties,
notably their parents,
but also their close kin.
Sometimes their brothers and sisters,
anyone who had an interest
that could see that that kind of
influence could sometimes be exerted quite
sensitively,
but sometimes it could be
asserted quite brutally.
Uh,
William Perkins,
the famous Puritan preacher,
uh,
advised one young woman who was worried
about the marriage that had been
proposed to her by her father.
He advised her live virginity
is not line to dispose of.
In part it is my parents.
They father had a stroke in it.
They mother hath another they
kindred half a third fight,
not against all,
but be his whom they would have the,
well in that case,
all that's required of her is her consent,
but it may have been very unwilling
among families that had little or no
property agreement or the goodwill,
as they often put it of others,
was largely a matter
of simply moral force.
Young people from the poorer ranks had
a good deal more freedom of movement.
Um,
they provided for their own independence
largely from their own earnings and
their own savings.
Um,
and often it took them years to do so,
um,
but they were under less
pressure from their families.
Um,
one young woman who was preparing for her
eventual independence as a young woman
called Isabel Fowler,
um,
who died unmarried around about 1550,
uh,
and whose goods were listed when she died.
Uh,
she was still a servant at the time.
She had a chest and in her chest she had
some clothes and some domestic utensils
and some bedding.
Uh,
her master was holding three pounds
of accumulated wages for her.
He was kind of acting as a banker.
And in addition,
uh,
she had three cows,
which are master was allowing
her to run a with his herd.
So Isabelle was clearly sort of getting
it together for a potential marriage.
Sadly,
she died.
She never made it,
but she would have been
a good catch if she had
well amongst people with property,
whether they were small farmers
or higher up to social scale.
The economic arrangements were
somewhat more complicated.
Uh,
one contemporary observers said,
young folk may come together for love,
but parents must cast how
they will live together.
The two families would provide,
um,
a conjugal fund.
The groom was expected.
It was expected that his family would
help to provide a dwelling and a means of
livelihood.
The bride would bring what
was called her portion,
her portion of goods or
money or perhaps even land,
uh,
with which our family would endow her.
These resources would be partly
accumulated by the young people,
but depended crucially at this
social level upon parental help,
through either inheritance
or transfers of property.
And the sums involved could,
could,
could be quite substantial.
Um,
in 1500 for example,
one study shows that the portions which
were given to daughters of the gentry in
the county of Kent,
which is down here in the southeast,
um,
averaged around 280 pounds is quite a
lot of money in the early 16th century,
which these gentry families had
to find for their daughters.
Um,
villagers in the same county of
course provided a much lower sums,
but it could range up to 20 or 30 pounds.
But whatever the level settling these
matters involve some pretty hard
bargaining amongst the family's concerned.
There's a lot of evidence of the way
in which people calculated what their
families could afford,
how the families of the bride and groom
hammered it out and negotiated over the
portions and all of this of course had
its implications for the younger children
in the family.
What would be left for them.
They had a say and they also needed to
calculate what the family could afford if
it was to remain itself
viable economically.
So it involved a lot of strategic thinking
when a marriage was proposed and if
all of that was successfully resolved,
the match would be concluded,
a new household would be established and
in doubt if not the denial of parental
support could be catastrophic
for the marriage.
Hopes of the young people concerned
if these things interests,
interests you.
I recommend in particular book
on the reading list by Diana.
Real horror core trip and constraint.
It's a wonderful study of
16th century courtship,
well putting your children fourth as
adolescence and then matchmaking at the
time of marriage.
We're also linked in different ways
to the question of inheritance,
the way in which resources were
transferred between the generations.
It's generally true to say that 16th
century English society and favored
primogeniture the lion's share going off
the family property going to the eldest
son.
But they also believe that an equitable
provision should be made for younger
children.
They should receive some portion of
goods to help them into adult life.
Uh,
one to the lawyer said that in his view,
a good and natural loving father would
exercise care and providence to advance
every office children according to his
ability with a portion of living or
substance.
And nor was it a matter for the father's
alone because if they laid down in
their wills,
the division of their goods
amongst their children,
it's also very clear that the successful
completion of these family strategies
usually depended upon the sustaining of
the household economy after the father's
death by their widows.
It was usual in people's wheels for the
widow to be named executor with full
control of the family property until
either her death or the age of majority of
the eldest son.
It was simply assumed that these women
had the experience and the capability to
do all that was required.
And that leads us to a final
aspect of the household.
The question of authority and power.
Yeah.
Within this structure of relationships.
All of the SEL strategies that I've
been talking about had a certain sort of
collective element.
You could say the quality of jointness,
the interests of the different
individuals intersect.
You'll have to accommodate the collective
interest of the household as a unit
with that of the individuals who comprised
it and had their own expectations and
perhaps ambitions.
Yeah.
But one might well ask whether decision
making within households was truly
connective
households,
uh,
like society in general.
What organized on a principle
of hierarchical differentiation,
people's duties and People's entitlements
were conceived of in accordance with
their place within that hierarchy.
The household economy,
as we've seen involved into dependence,
itch,
involved,
complementary effort,
but the contributions of members
will not necessarily of equal weight.
They weren't necessarily,
um,
of equal value in contemporary reviews.
Um,
one could say that in many ways the
house sold was in a sense a sphere of
altruism in which the interest of
others were taken into consideration.
But at the same time,
there could be clashes of personality
and there could be competition over
resources.
The law and contemporary ideology left
no doubt about where ultimate authority
lay in managing all of this.
It lay of course with the household head,
but it's equally apparent when one has
glimpses of households in action that the
personal dynamics of the household,
we're often far more complex than that
stereotype we have to stereotype of
uncontested patriarchal domination.
The reality turns out to
be far more very a gated.
The fact that women were subordinated
as a sex didn't preclude recognition of
their competence.
It didn't preclude
recognition of their judgment.
Such qualities were expected of them,
and they were daily displayed in
the conduct of household affairs.
As we've seen accordingly,
you find any evidence that wives were
very often far from being the silent
spectators of the decisions that were
made regarding their family's wellbeing.
The evidence of matchmaking shows that
they had a very real voice in either
negotiating the terms of the
marriages of their children or in um,
uh,
opposing or approving
particular candidates.
Um,
the evidence we have regarding the making
of people's wills shows that women are
often heavily involved advising their
husbands on the terms of their wills and
sometimes indeed,
uh,
disputing them.
They were the ones who would ultimately
have to administer and execute that was
Wales and they had a voice in their
making and they appear elsewhere making
their voices heard and
indeed being listened to
outside the context of the household.
Most women could of course
exercise little public authority,
but within it they clearly had a
recognized role and that recognized real
conferred certain rights and certain
entitlements and be for turbot in the book
of husbandry advised that both wife and
husband should from time to time make
what he called reckonings
with one another.
He was thinking of their
economic activities,
but they should make reckonings of their,
their activities with one another.
And he went on for if one of them
should use to deceive the other,
he deceived with himself and is not likely
to thrive and therefore they must be
true each to other.
That's just one statement of an
ideal of mutuality within marriage,
within the management of the household,
which of course found it's immediate
expression every day in the day to day
activities of households
that sin certainly didn't
transform them into spheres
of equality of course,
but it could and did involve the
development of working relationships,
of mutual support and mutual respect
in the pursuit of priorities that were
essentially shared.
So in short,
the household was certainly
a sphere of power.
It was certainly a sphere of authority,
but it was one in which the exercise was
also constantly influenced by the play
of the individual personalities
of those involved.
And I think if,
if one wants to work on
this kind of problem,
what needs to be sensitive to the
balance between these various elements?
So to conclude,
um,
society and economy in the early
modern period has been described by one
historian,
David Ralston as a culture of households.
In a landscape.
The household was certainly fundamental
and it was fundamental to both
continuity and change in the
social history of the period.
A lot of the characteristics that I've
been describing endured throughout the
whole of the 16th and 17th centuries,
but some aspects of
household life did change.
They changed with changing circumstances.
Some of the changes which took place in
this period in a variety of spheres in
the economy,
in population,
in social structure,
in culture had their influence
upon household relationships.
Some of them threatened the
viability of household economy,
some aspects of economic
and population change.
For example,
some changes provided new opportunities,
new opportunities for the
consumption of household goods,
new opportunities for the education of
children and other things which we'll see
in due course in later lectures
in general.
One could also say that the course of
change in this period and the outcomes of
change crucially involved the responses
to changing circumstances of thousands
of households and all of their
members had a hand in those responses.
It was never just a matter of impersonal
social forces acting upon households,
individuals and families
made their decisions,
adapted their strategies in
accordance with their values,
in accordance with their priorities
in meeting the various changes of the
period.
And thinking about that way is helpful,
I think,
um,
because when we think about it that way,
we can give some of the abstractions
and generalizations about the great
processes that took place
in the early modern period.
Something of a human face at
the level of the household.
And in many ways it,
it's the capacity of
historians to recapture the
shifting expressions on those
faces,
which makes these things worth studying.
Okay.
Well next time I'll go on to look at
various kinds of communities and their
institutions and patterns
of relationships.